Love him or hate him, there's no denying that
Adam Sandler knows how to entertain his fans.
And Netflix couldn't be happier with the results.
Since the company started producing its own
content in 2011, Netflix has sought out partnerships
with a variety of established producers, writers,
directors, and actors.
Many of these professionals are well-known
and respected within their industry, but that
clout doesn't always translate to audience
interest or attention.
The likes of Denzel Washington, Bong Joon
Ho, Charlie Kaufman, and Steven Soderbergh
have made movies for Netflix.
Celebrities such as Will Smith and Charlize
Theron have headlined major projects for the
streamer as well.
But even more so than film auteurs and action
stars, Adam Sandler is a brand unto himself.
Sandler has accumulated his fanbase over the
course of more than 30 years.
The comedian first became a household name
on "Saturday Night Live" where he was a cast
member from 1990 to 1995.
In short order, "SNL" launched Sandler into
a lucrative film career that began with 1995's
"Billy Madison" and continues to this day
with his Netflix deal.
"You want a piece of me?"
"I don't want a piece of you.
I want the whole thing!"
He's prolific, with more than 80 credits to
his name, and a few of his films are genuine classics.
One could argue that no "SNL" alum has had
Sandler's staying power.
Stars like Eddie Murphy, Mike Myers, and Will
Ferrell may have had higher highs, but they've
all fallen off for long periods and they've
struggled to maintain their leading man status
in more recent years.
Sandler is remarkably hard-working and consistent,
which is probably why Netflix was so eager
to bring him into their fold and is so happy
to keep him on board.
Sandler is no doubt best known for portraying
the doofus everyman.
In truth, there's not much difference between
Bobby Boucher and Hubie Dubois, and his fans
are fine with that.
Lowbrow comedies that are basically "SNL"
style sketches drawn out to 90-ish minutes
account for the bulk of his résumé.
And when he's not affecting a goofy accent
or involved in some form of hijinks, he often
stars in more traditional romantic comedies
or family movies like "50 First Dates," "Click,"
and "Pixels."
But while Sandler continues to make his traditional
comedy fair, he's also busy turning in praiseworthy
performances in awards-caliber films.
Many of these still qualify as comedies, though
some are significantly more highbrow, not
to mention dark.
Sandler's first foray into serious acting
came in Paul Thomas Anderson's 2002 dramedy
"Punch-Drunk Love."
That performance earned him a Golden Globe
nomination.
He received even more accolades for his role
as Howard Ratner in 2019's "Uncut Gems," though
he was snubbed for a widely expected Oscar
nod.
Beyond those critically praised roles and
over the top comedies, he's occasionally toned
things down in his movies.
This includes films for Netflix, like 2017's
"The Meyerowitz Stories (New and Selected)."
Most recently, he co-produced and led the
well-liked sports dramedy "Hustle" for the
streamer and, again, was a fixture on the
awards circuit.
In fact, in 2023, he was presented with the
Mark Twain Prize for American Humor.
Netflix surely wants Sandler for his signature
Happy Madison laugh riots, but it doesn't
hurt that he can also deliver powerhouse performances
in more grounded roles.
"Hey, do you love this game?
I love this game.
I live this game."
What does well in movie theaters has certainly
changed since the early days of Adam Sandler's
film career.
In the 1990s, studio comedies regularly topped
box office charts.
"Wayne's World," "Pretty Woman," "Ace Ventura:
Pet Detective," Sandler's own "The Waterboy,"
and "There's Something About Mary," were all
among the top 20 grossing films in the years
of their releases.
These days, it's unusual for a comedy of any
sort to crack that ceiling.
None managed it in 2022.
The Julia Roberts and George Clooney-led throwback
"Ticket to Paradise" was considered a triumph
when it managed to break into the top thirty.
By and large, comedies live on streaming platforms
now, and Netflix is an industry leader in
premiering lighthearted, non-IP fare directly
onto audiences' TVs.
There are several reasons for this and why
Sandler's movies in particular do so well
as a result of this shift in viewing habits.
Theatrical showtimes have been eaten up by
sprawling franchises like the MCU and the
"Avatar" series in part because customers
can justify paying for what feels like an event.
There's no rush to see a comedy.
They can't really be spoiled.
The visual effects aren't usually central
to the plot.
And while laughing as part of a group can
enhance the experience, that can still be
accomplished with friends and family in a
living room for the price of a monthly subscription.
Sandler's comedies are plentiful and broadly
appealing for those merely looking for something
fun to watch on Netflix.
Studio comedies disappeared from cinemas in
part because all mid-budget movies seemed
to vanish from the theatrical landscape.
This occurred because big-budget franchise
installments and low-budget horror flicks
started to squeeze them out.
Just last year, "Top Gun: Maverick" made nearly
$1.5 billion on a $170 million budget, while
the indie creep-fest "Skinamarink" made about
$2 million but cost only $15,000.
As of late, a $40 or $50 million comedy anchored
by a once-bankable A-lister seems like a gamble,
if not a losing bet.
So, slightly smaller-scale studio films have,
on the whole, migrated to streaming.
Netflix has signed several nine-digit multi-picture
agreements.
They forked over about $450 million for just
two of Rian Johnson's "Knives Out" sequels,
so Sandler's original deal, which guaranteed
him $250 million for four films, is a bargain
by comparison.
No details have been released about a new
commitment between Sandler and Netflix.
But comedies like his with a price tag of
roughly $60 million have, so far, clocked
in over 2 billion hours of viewing time.
It must be a good return on CEO Ted Sarandos'
investment.
Even projects that utterly miss the mark,
like 2015's spoof "The Ridiculous 6" are still
a low-risk, high-reward proposition both for
Netflix and for Sandler's Happy Madison production company.
"Well I have the microphone and you don't.
So you will listen to every damn word I have
to say!"
Moviegoers may have noticed that the length
of movies has been inching ever upward, especially
in the last few years.
Not that long ago, a three-hour-plus runtime
was extremely unusual, reserved only for the
occasional high fantasy or historical epic.
But last year, "RRR," "Babylon," and "Avatar:
The Way of Water," all surpassed the 180-minute mark.
Many more, including Steven Spielberg's autobiographical
family drama "The Fabelmans" and biopics "Blonde"
and "Elvis," hovered around two and a half
hours in length.
And Netflix's own "The Irishman" is a whopping
209 minutes long.
That can be daunting.
There's no question that patrons want to get
their money's worth out of a ticket, but there's
a limit to audiences' free time and attention
span.
Home viewing makes snacks and bathroom breaks
a little easier, but still, when subscribers
are browsing for something to watch, there's
less of a barrier when the runtime is cut
in half.
Sandler's trademark comedies tend to fall
somewhere between the 90- and 120-minute mark.
On the shorter end, the "Murder Mystery" movies
are a mere 97 and 90 minutes.
"Hubie Halloween" goes a breezy 103, and the
rest, "The Ridiculous 6," "The Do-Over," "The
Week Of," "The Meyerowitz Stories" and "Hustle,"
all come in under two hours.
That means even if home viewers aren't thrilled
with their choice, it won't be a slog to get through.
And if you wasted most of your night indecisively
scrolling through Netflix's infinite content
lineup, there's probably still time to fit
in an Adam Sandler movie.
Just as consumers' habits have evolved at
the movie theater, they've also evolved at
home too.
In the last year, streaming has surpassed
cable as the way most customers watch content.
One consequence of this significant paradigm
shift is that people no longer flip through
channels to find something to watch.
Nor do they leave whatever happens to be on
the TV as background noise.
These days, many viewers seek out specific
titles, particularly on the day of a new streaming release.
However, subscribers don't always want to
be so intentional.
Subscribers still use their TVs the way they
always have, as a means to…chill out.
Netflix has plenty of artistically ambitious
and thought-provoking original films to choose from.
"Beasts of the Southern Wild," "Roma," and
"All Quiet on the Western Front" are just a few.
But viewers aren't always in the mood for
something that requires them to put down their
phones and stay engaged, and definitely not
something that's academically or emotionally challenging.
Sometimes, audiences want a movie they can
tune in and out of.
Though the streamer has been desperate to
win a best picture Oscar and improve its critical
reputation, Netflix's customers love the platform
because of its accessible, binge-able, low-effort properties.
Most Sandler comedies fit that bill.
Even the more tightly plotted "Murder Mystery
2" doesn't require the brain power of "Glass Onion."
When it comes to how subscribers commonly
use the service, Sandler and Netflix's laid-back,
hang-out vibes are a perfect match for each
other.
Six degrees of Adam Sandler
The entertainment industry isn't as star driven
as it once was, but audiences still like to
see their favorites on screen.
It's even better when they're paired up together.
If his friends and co-workers are to be believed,
Sandler is one of the most humble and down-to-earth
celebrities working today.
Because he's easy to work with, other big-name
actors and directors are happy to get involved
in whatever he's got going on.
Sandler regulars like David Spade and Kevin
James tend to pop up in most of his projects,
which is a clear indicator of how much he
inspires loyalty.
But he also brings along old pals like Jennifer
Aniston and Chris Rock.
Celebrated directors and producers have conceived
films with the comedian in mind too, which
is a luxury not many actors enjoy.
Paul Thomas Anderson considered himself an
"obsessive" Sandler fan.
And so he challenged himself to make an arthouse
version of a Sandler comedy with "Punch-Drunk Love."
Though it's not currently on Netflix in the
United States, the connection between the
director and actor that developed because
of that film gave Sandler some impressive
indie cred.
Later, Sandler teamed up with writer-director
Noah Baumbach for Netflix's "The Meyerowitz
Stories," which co-stars Ben Stiller as his
brother.
Then, in 2022, Sandler got some of the best
reviews of his career for Netflix's "Hustle."
He co-produced the basketball dramedy with
LeBron James.
In the end, millions of Adam Sandler fans
seek out his movies on Netflix.
But, because he has such a variety of famous
co-stars and collaborators, their fans end
up seeking out his movies as well.
Despite his intermittent critical acclaim
and the fleeting brilliance of ideas like
"The Chanukah Song," Adam Sandler probably
doesn't come to mind when film buffs think
about the world's best actors.
And that's part of his appeal.
He's the type of performer who understands
his strengths and understands exactly how
to push himself when he chooses to.
Where Sandler has truly excelled in his 30-plus-year
career is as a producer.
Not only has he figured out a filmmaking formula
that's practically market and critic-proof,
but he's actually ahead of the curve when
it comes to trends.
He's proven himself extremely savvy about
the types of movies he makes and when he releases them.
A perfect example is when The first "Murder
Mystery" dropped on Netflix roughly six months
before "Knives Out."
He released the entertaining whodunit at exactly
the right time before the much bigger movie
premiered in theaters.
He also headlined the emotional Noah Baumbach
family drama "The Meyerowitz Stories" two
years before Adam Driver did the same in "Marriage
Story."
And he released his well-regarded sports movie
"Hustle" before 2023's "Air," "Champions"
and "Challengers."
He diversifies his portfolio more than it
might seem.
Sandler has lent his voice to animated movies
like the "Hotel Transylvania" franchise.
And he had the business acumen to make one
of his many broad appeal comedies, "Hubie
Halloween," a holiday offering.
It practically assures repeat yearly viewing
as a result.
The unassuming actor, writer, and producer
continues to conquer streaming because he
grasps how best to reach and grow his audience
using Netflix.